[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
oh yeah
energy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
boy
[Music]
yes
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
snippet of fire flow from me that was
taken up at Great Lakes flow Retreat
based just outside of Detroit Michigan
big thank you to the wonderful Folks up
at Great Lakes flow for having me up
there and giving me an opportunity to
check out their wonderful event for the
first time you should definitely check
it out too speaking of thank yous uh big
thanks is owed to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel That is Becca
becklinman thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission also this video would not be
possible without the kind support of all
of these lovely people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon they
in the the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support if you out there
watching like the work that I produce
and you'd like to see more of it you can
support me in doing it by heading on
over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a variety of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission of
bringing POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you if you'd like
to see more videos of me spin fire and
performing in general I will go ahead
and include a link to a playlist of said
videos down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you're watching
on YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video here because it's popular amongst
other viewers of my channel so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow yourself today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon
peace